こんちゃっす初めて超です皆さんだいぶあったかい季節になってきましたね暑い季節と
いえば何か
そう
春夏の暑い季節といえば hello hello がとても why 好きなんです
よね
やっぱこう心霊スポットにも僕も行きたくなっちゃいますし新年の映画誰も見たくなっ
てしまうそれがやっぱね過労がいいと思うんですよ
あ
ホラーね発音が良すぎるすいませんでしたそんなホラーの時期なんですけども
ホランのドッキリって言ってもないかも簡単だ結構決まっちゃってて何かに隠れて
ガーってなら強いのが出てくるとかクラークして明るくしたのはって何ゲットできると
かいろんなパターンがあると思うんですけども僕が市の声と思う心霊系のドッキリとし
てはいない場所から急に出てくるのが一番怖いと思うんですよ
なんかその
真っ赤になったらなんか出てくるとかもよくあるしなんか開けたら出てくるもまあまあ
あるんですよ
普通でてございましたから出てくる幽霊とかいつも声と思うんですよ
例えば多く場とか絶対人が出てこないような高さな場所と a 場所から急に人が
終わって出てくるとめちゃくちゃ敗と思うんで今日はそれを実際に再現してみようと
思います大根
旅のアイゼン早速つっていきましょう今回のちょっとイメージとしては感激のなぜかと
貞子チックのお姉さんが3階のベランダかけるってくっていうことでございますね人だ
と持ち上がらないのでちょっと頑張って超軽量化したさだとお姉さんを作ってみようと
思いますようなものを色々買ってきました
タタコっぽいスク12,800円しましためっちゃ長いですよ人とか
そしてこれ
聞いてたらもうさたコンボイなってるわけでこれを買ってこの数はですねちょっと
髪の毛長めのカツラを用意しました
コツは15000円です結構長いよねー多分前かがみになるんでうわぁ
by mcm よねこんな感じでございますそして肝心な顔をツアーでございますよ
[音楽]
ウールうんきれいな川なんですけど汚れ等があるとと怖いですよねまぁ他にも色々ある
んですけども基本的にこちらで作っていきましょう
行ってあげさせてまずさなこちゃんをつくっていきましょうだけでまずこの子に
ハンガーで肩幅をつけますこの子3階まで打ち上げれば今回の作戦なんでまずは軽量化
のめちゃくちゃ軽い沙汰を作ることがございますこれで貼っとけば方
ば作れるんでまずハンガーとこの子を合体させます
そうですおっ教育これでも落ちることはないでしょう
失礼しましたこれでこの子に服を着てれるようになったというわけですから結局髪の毛
て確率んでなんかだいたいでいいんスよね人の形大バカでも強いと思うんでどう
でしょうねあーやんぺーなポロリ
だいぶ胸やばタイプー貞子ちゃんを作っている時にも居場所を持ってしまいました
なんかここがすごいやら結構暖房でいるだけだけど
これどうすかねえ次は悪いけど初級名なら
まあな元でいいんじゃないかしらちょっと簡易的な気もしますよいや十分超えと思い
ます
かっその逆につけちゃえば風
ああ怖いこれ怖いよ3階とか屋上とかですよな絶対人が来ないであろうベランダから
打ってくるんですよ
怖いでしょキュッじゃあこれを何とかして3階まで持っていく方法を知られます1回
ちょっとに行きましょ入ってくれ外に行きました
ここの3階ですねここらへんここにターゲットおびき寄せて
魚ってここから貞子さんだしたいんで何が欲しいかと言います高さですよね
絶対前話をの釣竿の先端にさぼちゃんをつけて
多分これでギリギリ里から未来が見えないくらいだと思います結局ツイザーだ星なるん
で先っぽの方ちょっと亀テープで他のボートくっつけて固めようと思います
[音楽]
できましたえッちなるんだけど南新地なる鹿島がないかの間です多分大丈夫だよ
入って言うけど若干しなるんですけども一朝年間ただ骨は持ち上げるぐらいなのかなと
思えるぐらいの釣竿が出来ました若干不安なんですよね
はいという意味でさらに強化してめちゃくちゃもしならがすぎる
釣り竿準備しました
[音楽]
いっエメットいい感じだねこれたぶん生きる勢いでいければ服を着てます
きたきたきたきたーい
ただ鬘を被ってればたぶんこのねぇこれ結構いいぞ
一応完成しましたんですけどこれがちゃんと植えて立つかどうかですね
1回上に行ってみます
ん花王
道
どうですか自分で確認します
あー声はあなたがまだ完成じゃねえ
いーのーりーだー貞子って血が付いてるイメージがあるんですよね
今でも一番二世の服用すの家だな
や早すぎだたいなやべあとはターゲットが来てベランダから古木の飛び込むだけで済め
ばターゲットを待ちましょう
今日
[音楽]
立ってるん
ああああグランデも食べた井村空美そしてっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
していた
闇てる感じなんでしょはいはーい
今日はこの本番を一応
[音楽]
初めて運営委員
me
[音楽]
キャッチャーすんだろだって9 notes れの女の子だけどそれ
んが
wh
をやってい
はありません
はぁ
びっこ
しっ
んんん
ああああああ
分かってるんだよ w
バッグわー
[音楽]
me
dea
ana あった
うわーうわー
うわあああっはい